endurance running is a fast growing
Sport and race fees don't come cheap so
no wonder the target market is the fast
living High earning professional the
goal is to keep fit clear the head and
put your body and mind through the
ultimate test let's do a run through of
the different projects on our plate
right now so um first up is I think
running especially distance running
which is what I do um one thing that
really helps me to get through the
running is really breaking it down into
SE
Hong Kong born English educated Moi lamb
is the joint head of the corporate
finance group at UBS her last race saw
her jog self-supported across 250 km of
mainly desert Coastline rainforest and
hard terrain and in the Searing 40° heat
of Madagascar all in only 7 days and
here's the rub she paid for it a $35,000
entry fee for the privilege I joined Moi
on one of her training runs okay so this
is your backpack but before you put that
on this is fine before you put that on
of course we're going to add some weight
onto it into it so it's 5 kilos of rice
which is um what I always train with
actually usually train with more than
that usually like a one 5 kilo bag of
rice plus 5 L of water so that makes it
makes it 10 10 kilos on your back okay
after you okay go back
good for many the incentive is about
giving back moiz was exactly this and
each leg stood for a charity Habitat for
Humanity which helps house the world's
poor while rain Lily helps women deal
with the trauma of sexual violence by
finishing Madagascar 2014 Moi lamb
raised
$410,000 us so the hardest part for me
was the last 12 km on the long day of
the 80 km basically I by that time I had
like a dozen blisters on my feet and
they were already painful to start with
but somehow you know after most after
the majority of day five they just
decided that they've had enough and the
pain barrier that I built up just
suddenly vanished time to eat right
glucose drink that's not even half of my
short training we should go a few more
laps J okay may have a really good time
well as mie heads off again training for
her next endurance race somehow she has
to balance a banking career career but
remember this it's all for two good
causes and that's her motivation John
Dawson Bloomberg on the peak in Hong
Kong